und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und claus kleber
guten abend man muss sich schon wundern
nach mehr als anderthalb jahren corona
pandemie wird weiter über ganz
grundsätzliches gestritten
was soll der maßstab sein für den grad
der gefahr für reisen und rückkehr für
quarantäne für test und möglicherweise
irgendwann sogar impfpflicht inzidenz
oder was alles unbestimmt alles in
bewegung und irgendwie auch alles
treibholz auf den wellen des wahlkampfes
während das virus neue fakten schafft
und die hoffnungen durchkreuzt das 50 60
prozent durch impfungen die pandemie
doch schon halbwegs ausbremsen könnte
neue zahlen aus den usa zeigen so
einfach wird das nicht nicht mit dieser
variante delta es müssen weiter regeln
gelten es müssen entscheidungen fallen
heike slansky berichtet noch ist der
kurs nicht klar
unterwegs in mecklenburg vorpommern der
hoffnungsträger der spd auf stimmenfang
an themen mangelte es nicht was tun zum
beispiel gegen die impfquote die trotz
steigender infektionszahlen stagniert
scholz bleibt sich treu seine losung
bloß keinen verschrecken kein impfzwang
stattdessen sanftes zu reden
wichtig ist dass wir die möglichkeiten
eröffnen die stehen bereit und dass wir
jetzt alle die impf angebote den dort
schon existieren insofern noch
attraktiver machen dass es auf suchen.de
angebote gibt und dass man auch nicht
mehr an termine gebunden ist impfen was
das zeug hält da kommt die entscheidung
der sächsischen impfkommission die
einzige ausländer ebene manchen
politikern vielleicht gerade recht denn
entgegen der empfehlung der ständigen
impfkommission der stiko rät sie nun
plötzlich impfen schon ab 12 jahren
es ist ein angebot an alle so wie es
auch an die älteren angebot ist das ist
ja keine impfpflicht das muss man noch
mal ganz klar sagen die wollen wir gar
nicht sondern wir wollen den ärzten und
ärzten ermöglichen kinderärzte aber auch
haushalts und hausärzten dass die mit
dieser empfehlung sich sicher fühlen
auch kinder und jugendliche zu impfen
meinungsverschiedenheiten nicht nur
unter fachleuten auch die politik erhöht
den druck schäuble söder oder lauterbach
sie alle über stimmen die empfehlung der
eigenen experten sehr zum ärger vieler
akteure sollen wir ganz großen
fehlentwicklungen das einfach dieses
verhältnis von wissenschaft und politik
an vielen stellen schwer beschädigt ist
und der druck der von manchem minister
sind nicht von allen
auch die stiko ausgeübt wird ist aus
meiner sicht wirklich aufs schärfste zu
kritisieren kinder impfen ja oder nein
ein glaubenskrieg die politik möchte es
so leicht wie möglich machen wie hier
beim volksfest in nürnberg doch auch in
sachsen überwiegt die skepsis zufalls
umfrage ich weiß nicht warum die
sächsische da so vorprescht ich bin
grundsätzlich schon auch dafür dass da
mehr studien gemacht werden gerade was
kinder betrifft war ja auch immer wieder
gesagt wird dass kinder gar nicht so
sehr betroffen sind eine empfehlung kann
man gehen gegen eine impfpflicht wäre
ich aber ich finde empfehlung für kinder
wird es schon bei erwachsenen fraglich
und bei kilo nicht der kampf gegen die
verunsicherung und die impfmüdigkeit
auch das bundeseigene forschungsinstitut
erhitzt die gemüter das rki empfiehlt
nach anderthalb jahren pandemie die
inzidenz müsse der leitindikatoren
bleiben kritik von der
krankenhausgesellschaft wenn wir jetzt
nur bei der incidents bleiben und sehen
steigende zahl nach den sommerferien
dann wird man möglicherweise sehr
spontan auf die idee kommen die schulen
wieder flächendeckend zu schließen
wir glauben wir müssen unbedingt die
altersgruppen berücksichtigen wir müssen
auch schauen gibt es wirklich schwerere
verläufe auch unter den jungen wie
manche behaupten
all diese erkenntnisse haben sie nicht
wenn sie nur auf die inzidenz blick
genommen die politik im zugzwang
getrieben von einem unberechenbaren
virus mitten im wahlkampf und zum
anderen großen thema dieser tage man
will sich als erstes ein bild von der
lage machen heißt es immer nach
katastrophen das zweite große bild sah
so aus nach der flut wie hier in bad
münstereifel das wahre ausmaß der
katastrophe erschließt sich aber erst
wenn man die details sieht peter böhme
schaut genauer hin
ein leeres kellerfenster und dann
baumelt plötzlich ein absaug schlaff
herunter
der ganze keller von hans thelen war
vollgelaufen
schlimmer noch die rohrleitung zu den
öltanks wurde zerstört
eine rote heizöl wasser schlamm mensch
war bat nun über den boden es stinkt
immer noch nach öl aber kein vergleich
zu vorher wirklich neben tankstelle
stehen und von benzin ihnen danken
riechen einfluss stütze das
öl-wasser-gemisch will thelen schnell
raus haben erst dann kann das
unbewohnbare erdgeschoss getrocknet
werden
die trocknungsgeräte würden sonst den
gestand durchs haus pusten um die 6000
liter schwappen in keller und tanks und
diese probleme haben tausende haushalte
in den katastrophengebieten
wir gehen davon aus dass sich
wahrscheinlich mehrere millionen litern
heizöl und diesel benzin und sonstigen
betriebsstoffen freigesetzt wurden durch
die durch das schadenereignis die anzahl
der gebäude die davon direkt oder
indirekt betroffen sind können wir noch
gar nicht quantifizieren und das will
sollte schnell aus den gebäuden wegen
des geruchs und war heizöl die bitumen
schichten angreift die die mauern in
jedem haus vor feuchtigkeit schützen
dadurch verlieren sie ihre dichtungs
funktion und die folge ist das mauerwerk
was vorher geschützt war gegen
feuchtigkeit jetzt eben ungeschützt oder
nur noch teilweise geschützt ist und die
folge davon ist dann sie haben
anschließend feuchte kellerräume
auch die industrie hat das problem zwei
tanklaster sondern in diesem müll
entsorgungsbetrieb ein vollgelaufen des
regenrückhaltebecken leerpumpen
zigtausende liter dreckiger schwarzer
schlamm das hochwasser stand hier bis
zur beton strebe also höher als die
tanklastzüge
würde ich das alles unter wasser standen
das morgens betrieb hier wieder alles
drin sein hausmüll fäkalien alles diesel
denke ich mir die ganzen morastigen flut
rückstände sind allerdings auch rohstoff
in dieser spezialfirma am niederrhein
werden schlamm öl und wasser getrennt
das wasser etwa sieht dann so aus wird
weitergeleitet in kläranlagen aus den
ölen wird nach der trennung schmieröl
kann verkauft werden und die
laboruntersuchungen brachten
beruhigendes zu tagen wir dürfen
momentan aber sagen dass wir keine
problematischen stoffe weder chlor noch
pcb oder ähnliches lokalisieren konnten
in den krisengebieten
die wir letztendlich abgefahren haben
oder die über mit mitbewerber gefahren
worden sind die ihre flüssigkeiten
positionieren
von daher bin ich trotz der miserablen
situation sehr zuversichtlich
bei herrn thelen sieht es nach drei
stunden arbeit auch schon wieder etwas
besser aus
ende des jahres will er sein haus wieder
bezugsfertig haben
es ist aber schon noch ein weiter weg
vor hans thelen und die vielen familien
denen es so geht wie ihm fast 64
millionen euro sind da gott sei dank
schon zusammengekommen durch spenden
hilfsbereiter zdf zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer
wenn sie dabei sein wollen bei dieser
schönen erfolgsgeschichte ist hier die
bank adresse des aktionsbündnisses
katastrophenhilfe bahn.de 65/100 400 600
nochmal 100 400 600 stichwort zdf
hochwasser weitere informationen auf
spenden zdf de und im zdf text und nun
nachrichten von gundula gab so offenbar
sind im landkreis ahrweiler am tag vor
der flutkatastrophe präzise warnungen
eingegangen
auf die nicht rechtzeitig reagiert wurde
die frankfurter allgemeine zeitung
berichtet unter berufung auf das
rheinland pfälzische landes und das
schon am nachmittag wasser höchststände
prognostiziert und entsprechende
warnungen herausgegeben wurden
der landkreis ahrweiler hatte aber erst
gegen 23 uhr den katastrophenfall
ausgerufen
das thw hat in bad neuenahr eine erste
behelfsbrücke über die aa fertiggestellt
weitere sind geplant
mehr als 80 brücken sind durch die
fluten beschädigt oder komplett zerstört
in mehreren mittelmeeranrainer ländern
wüten weiter heftige waldbrände in der
türkei stieg die zahl der todesopfer auf
6 und auch auf sizilien bedrohen mehr
als ein dutzend brände mensch und natur
nahe der küstenstadt catania wurden 170
anwohner in sicherheit gebracht der
flughafen musste kurzzeitig den betrieb
einstellen
meteorologen in italien griechenland und
der türkei erwarten noch für die ganze
kommende woche eine dauer hitze von über
40 grad in der türkischen stadt konya
sind sieben mitglieder einer kurdischen
familie getötet worden
aus mutmaßlich rassistischen motiven
angreifer waren in das haus der familie
eingedrungen hatten die bewohner
vossen und ein feuer gelegt zehn
verdächtige wurden festgenommen
der türkische innenminister wies die
rassismus darstellung zurück und sprach
von einer familienfehde am dritten
wochenende in folge gibt es in
frankreich proteste gegen die korona
politik der regierung die behörden gehen
von etwa 200.000 demonstranten im ganzen
land aus ihr protest richtet sich gegen
die impfpflicht für bestimmte
berufsgruppen aber auch gegen den
gesundheitspass der zeigt ob man geimpft
genesen oder getestet ist
allein in paris waren mehr als 3000
polizisten im einsatz
das klang jetzt nicht unbedingt wie gute
werbung für urlaub in frankreich aber es
gibt die lage im land auch nur
unvollständig wieder unser paris
korrespondent thomas walde berichtet aus
der britannia dass urlauber aus
deutschland dort sehnlichst erwartet und
die vorschriften vernünftig eingehalten
werden auch von den bretonen den anderen
franzosen eine gewisse dickköpfigkeit
gegenüber anordnungen aus paris nach
sagen
ungültig ihr gesundheitspass ist nicht
gültig und ihrer auch nicht sie müssten
bitte beide jetzt einen kurve test
machen und mit negativem ergebnis wieder
herkommen die nächste apotheke dafür ist
etwa zwei kilometer von hier entfernt
der urlaub auf diesem campingplatz im
kern zurück in der bretagne beginnt für
einige reisende mit einer überraschung
der in frankreich jetzt vorgeschriebene
gesundheitspass wird tatsächlich
kontrolliert unsere zweite impfung haben
wir heute morgen bekommen aber sie muss
mindestens sieben tage her seien jetzt
machen wir einen test war sound terni
hält sich auf seinem campingplatz an die
auflagen er will keine strafen riskieren
viele besucher sagt er tun sich schwer
sich anzupassen
wir haben für gewöhnlich 80 prozent
franzosen und 20 prozent ausländer
in diesem jahr sind es nur fünf prozent
ausländer die herkommen unsicherheit
schwappt an die bretonische küste wie
hier in konto das virus kommt und geht
und kommt wieder und mit ihm immer neue
regeln theorie theresa beobachtet dass
mancher keine lust mehr hat damit zu
machen
sie hatten große probleme leute zu
finden den kongo vielen derzeit 150 bis
180 saison arbeiter dabei hat con carne
schon einiges erlebt davon zeugen die
bilder nebenan im museum von porta war
sie erzählen die geschichte der region
und da relativiert sich auch cupid in
der kunstgeschichte findet man mitunter
darstellungen der pest etwa oder ähnlich
schlimme aber da sind wir ja mit cupid
noch nicht und hoffen mal dass es dabei
bleibt
einen gewissen humor haben sie sich hier
bewahrt dieser herr saugt die gegend
förmlich auf und macht seine geschichten
daraus jörg bong schreibt krimis als
jean-luc ballack ist er auch hier
bekannt cupid verändert etwas sagt er
und nicht nur zum negativen die
franzosen haben die britannia entdeckt
wiederentdeckt es ist so nah es ist
sicher und es geht einher mit mit einer
art besinnung spazieren wirklich wandel
rogan eher sachen die meditativ sind
kontemplativ ruhig zur natur zurück zur
natur abgelegen und individuell wird und
die verschärften regeln gibt es auch
hier aber die britannia zeigt gerade in
diesen tagen dass sie doch viel mehr ist
als nur das der beginn der schulferien
hierzulande in bayern und baden
württemberg hat zu massiven staus
geführt
entsprechend eng wurde es vor allem auf
bayerischen autobahnen wo reisende
stundenlange verzögerungen in kauf
nehmen mussten
während im süden deutschlands den
sommerferien beginnen startet im norden
und osten bald wieder die schule durch
reiserückkehrer staute sich der verkehr
daher auch in richtung nord- und ostsee
die lottozahlen lauten ohne gewähr 1 48
24 26 39 superzahl 5 mehr auf lotto zdf
de und im zdf text auf seite 5 56 und
das wetter bleibt unbeständig und
vergleichsweise kühl dabei regnet es
morgen im nordwesten und südosten häufig
südlich der donau auch anhaltend stark
sonst gibt es einen sonne wolken mix mit
einzelnen schauern und gewittern
bei 15 bis 23 grad auch in der neuen
woche bleibt es vor allem in der mitte
bei dem wechselhaften wetter so wie er
frischen 18 bis 24 grad
das letzte bett also mehr zur bewegung
im freien ein als zum liegen in der
sonne
das war es von uns ein schönes
wochenende sagen wir und bis morgen